they said an animal has it they said an
animal has it
could you imagine you're on Noah's Ark
and they got in this and this animal
shows up oh yeah you heard a little
Perry the pigeon he's got it and he's oh
he's trying he's trying the pigeon just
kind of wandering around trying not to
see anybody you know try not to let
anybody notice him all sneezing into his
own little pigeon arm this thing who
know where is it it's like
hide-and-go-seek with the devil huh
Rhona boy that Rona
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wandering how could I be so far oh and
my mom is somewhere else but when I
found it our patch up where it's pinned
wrong come on now let's go now I'm just
floating on the breeze these leaves that
must be cornerstone come on
no time to feel bad the day baby let's
go
[Music]
for me to set that parking brake
myself
[Music]
- all singing just for you
I've been moving way too fast
I've been moving way too fast that is
shine by Bishop gun and that is a
beautiful band and group of men and
rarely a lot of time if you see a men
get together it's for you know it's fur
it can be for sex it could be for music
and then this instance is for music and
that's beautiful man
PTL baby praise the Lord this Bishop
Gunn was shine right there and we are
alive they were alive we are alive check
it look to put two fingers on your on
your damn neck pipe bro
yeah and feel that pump @e up you know
what I'm saying that's that that's that
living giving bra that's your heart
shooting just do the heart will just
shoot blood out all day
a heart is baby just basically just a
machine gun of blood you just the thing
is savage bro man you think about it
probably one of the top three organs I
think overall good to be here with you
guys it is April
it is 2020 2020 and it's getting clearer
man is getting clearer people out
there's getting wicked people anything
it just squirrely out there you don't
even know what animal has it bro
you see a falcon go by he might have it
you see a little while um you see a
labradoodle sneak over and he's trying
to lick your arm or something lick your
navel you know sometimes I used to put a
little meat paste in my navel bruh and
my neighbors had a little while it was
like a miniature arm little I don't know
what it was
Tom Moran
miniature pom I ran and I put a little
meat paste in my navel and his name was
Barker Brown I'd let him suck that you
know not suck it but kind of lick it out
and this you know this human animal
relations brother and I was you know I
was happy to be part of that as a you
know when I was young but now can you
even can you trust an animal who can you
trust
welcome to hide-and-go-seek 2020 that's
what's going on it's getting wicked we
caught up thank you guys for being here
yeah and I hope I hope you guys I hope
people holding it together keeping their
heads together you know you got a you
got a really got to be a warrior right
now because some people keep saying oh I
can't get it oh I ain't getting it you
know you hear a lot of rumors Oh gay men
can't get it oh we can't get it yes you
can
Alan all right y'all can get it
everybody can get it oh my you know my
cousins in the military man I can't get
it yes you can Samuel you can get it
everybody can get it just a lot of bad
rumors a lot of bad Intel out there a
lot of bad mental hearsay oh well you
know Oh black like women are we can get
it yeah you can
Kisha everybody can get it it's just
it's a disease man it's a virus and
everybody can get it and it's so sneaky
[Music]
like I wonder if you if the corona virus
was a person it's so it would have like
a mustache and what happened like it
would have regular glasses and
sunglasses
it's so like oh oh it's it's like it
would probably talk like this oh I don't
speak English it would say [ __ ] like
that I don't speak on low Woma from your
Karuna viruses sneak when I was young
they had more less sneaky diseases
remember that do you remember when we
were kids that the diseases were real
they had our chickenpox because somebody
had hugged a chicken for too long and if
you do that you break out because these
spots come out of your body because God
wants other people to know hey this is
the type of person that will hug a
chicken for much longer than they should
and so you know what I'm saying so you
get chicken pox but they were obvious
diseases you know you knew so you saw
somebody with chicken pox over they got
a chicken pox you know you saw somebody
with a um mustache oh they got a
mustache things were obvious but now
it's getting covert it's getting risque
as they call it but yeah what would
coronavirus be wearing probably like a
turtleneck like a sleeveless turtleneck
yeah oh I don't know I'm not from around
here
it would be so sneaky it's a sneaky
disease man we've had a lot of calls
that came in a lot of people hitting us
up just seeing what's going on what's up
with me right now you know there's a
there's not a ton to say I've been doing
you know I watched the comedy gives back
I watched as much of that as I could if
you got to see it I think they raised
like oh I want to say like I don't even
know how much they finished raising but
I can imagine it's up near probably
$700,000 for comedians to you know to
you know people that are you know in the
comedy community that are struggling and
that are out of work and so that was
really beautiful then it was a damn
basket fire dude if you freaking had a
cousin made out of gasoline and you
[ __ ] fed him matches for his birthday
that's what this [ __ ] was it was just
audio difficulties dissing
and it was like remember when you got
one of those shitty us those sprint
phones those next hell's or whatever but
you could only you could call people but
then you could just talk to also you
could talk to one person you could call
anybody you want it but then you be in
the middle of a call like yeah
everything's going good
every and then you're cut your cousin or
somebody Fire Department whoever the
only other person that had the walkie
your girlfriend Chuck we need some
[ __ ] milk you back up and you've got
honey hop hold a hole hold on buddy
remember that thing that next no way
make some [ __ ] milk Randall you like
aw oh [ __ ]
Oh hold on Damien Oh must be lines must
be crossed up and then you slick sneak
click over Psalms I'm sorry I'll be
right there
the author there's a long line bring the
[ __ ] line you're lying
oh sorry man I gotta go bro remember
that [ __ ] next Ella [ __ ] was Brian
horns dude it looked like it looked like
you
they had it colored because it looked
like you were gonna need to be rescued
like anytime you get that bright colored
[ __ ] bro that's [ __ ] a lot of real
poor like sale racks have like real
colorful bright [ __ ] like oh look at
this don't you want this hot orange and
this [ __ ] is hot orange like the hottest
orange you could get is three dollars
three dollars and for 40 cents for this
7xl and it's like a [ __ ] v-neck
v-neck in the front turtleneck in the
back
you're like what and it's hot hot orange
bra and it's always usually a but it's
only a black dude could wear it let's be
honest bro only a black dude could wear
it and
a little good handyman it'll be triple
lime that's the color you'll see on the
thing it'll be bright bright green the
kind of [ __ ] like you can't the guy like
if you drive past it on the interstate
it's obviously the definite manager of
the guy who is doing the construction
it's that it's like triple lime in its
size 14 double medium bro and that [ __ ]
got two arms in the front it's got an
arm out the back for exhaust like heat
exhaust as [ __ ] is I don't know we're
talking about bright colors they got
bright colored [ __ ] and it's mostly it's
predominantly a lot of times for the
urban community let's be honest but cuz
they look good in it you know if white
people wear really bright colors should
it look like they need to be rescued
real talking look black people wear
something low that's triple lime Oh
Ernie got that triple lime hitter on Oh
woah he must be getting married you know
oh he got that triple I'm [ __ ]
overcoat with that double vanilla
cumberbund bro oh he must be he must be
doing a wedding but if a white dude goes
with that bright [ __ ] they look it's
definitely rescue only you know that
[ __ ] let's rescue only let's take a call
that came in as always the hotline nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three gang gang what's up man this is
dusty from Leesburg Georgia
what's up dusty over here in Leesburg
huh and Leesburg Georgia and that is um
man I sound like a small place that's
not like kind of place where everybody
kind of you know where the water
fountain is you know it sound like you
could definitely go find a wishing well
over there beautiful
oh we're brother I just want to call in
was install so much coronavirus I love
kind of sick of this half apocalypse
everything shut down half still going
work paying my bills which I am
appreciative of because I understand
there's a lot of people out there
without work
able to pay the bills but uh I mean yeah
I just figure fledgling in the middle
here we need to choose the side either
everything just needs to go back to how
it was and we figure the [ __ ] out that
way or we go full [ __ ] apocalypse and
we get a couple of dune buggies and a
couple of sets the shoulder pants start
shaving her head to the mohawk speaking
simpler languages you know a man I'd
look there's that Ella everybody that's
what I'm saying where everybody's a
lesbian you know I'm saying you fold
your weight your nuts into something and
you next thing you know you got some for
just down there and everybody's a
everybody's a Les Deux Mohawks on
everybody you know what I'm saying
ladies trim your tits down guys sharpen
up your lower ribs and expose Umbra and
let's [ __ ] go toe-to-toe look there's
something to be said there's a there's
the I think that seed is like that that
seed lives in a lot of us somewhere that
element of anarchy you know what I'm
saying we got that [ __ ] violent onion
smelling up our insides you know that
thing is in there and not there's a lot
of people who are who are who are kind
of like a society Sh'ma sia t they don't
feel that the you know the Rhonda John
or the you know the this this human
gumbo that we have going on is the best
is the best for its not that it's not
the it doesn't really fulfill their
appetite but I feel it there's this
middle ground thing like okay like okay
like I don't have my windows tinted on
my on my truck right so I'm at that
point where I'm like okay do I need can
I go get them tinted or can I break them
all out and hire a couple of straight-up
beautiful ass [ __ ] lean lean with it
rock with it vietze to hang out the back
and shoot with slingshots as I go as I
Drive like that's where I'm at
like what things do I need to do and
what things can I not like like where am
I at like okay can I still go to the
grocery or is it okay to just turn my
living room into a damn garden okay cuz
I got enough room for three rows of
sweet patate right in front of the damn
ottoman and right before you get to that
um dual deck CD uh ten disc er you know
I there's it's it's just kind of
everything's in the middle like what do
I got two sides in my sink in my kitchen
like do I still need to just do the
dishes at night or I do I need to plug
both of those [ __ ] up and start
raising farm fresh salmon and one half
of it and shrimp and the other you feel
me you know I was gonna have some shrimp
so there's that middle ground there it's
like okay
or you know am I still married to my
wife like how weird this [ __ ] have to
get before I'm just like how long does
the courthouse have to be closed down
before I can this kind of walk on off
you know but before the marriage
certificate there's nowhere to even go
cash that thing in it it's interesting
it's interesting because society is just
like kind of a stack of things that
happen you know man gets a little
property he gets a wife and then they
have a family and then you know enough
family's needed uh we're teaching their
kids and say well okay let's you know we
got too many kids let's hire just one
person to teach them all and so then
then one person was the best part the
best teacher in the neighborhood became
the teacher and the kids all went to her
and that's how a school started then you
got a school and he said this man over
here okay I'm good at making uh boots
I'll make all the boots
alright cool Donnie you do the boots now
buck yellow you to boot man Donnie and
everybody gets their thing and it builds
but then man it's definitely there's a
little bit of jiangha in the air it's
like okay we've been there's a lot has
been this thing's been this thing's
starting to sway in the wind a little
you know these step kids are a how you
know they're not even really mine at
this point shits hitting the fan they're
not doing [ __ ] they in there they on the
tablets all day they every time I orange
comes off our orange tree they get out
there and sneak it I'm saying daddy I
don't have any vitamin C my spines
getting all [ __ ] bent out because I
don't have the proper vets in me what's
going on you know it's do I still have
to be a stepparent like that you know
things it's gonna get interesting man
but I feel you I wish they would just
shut the news down and say hey look it's
every man for himself but then also
that's just a little part of me that
wants that the other part of me is like
a man let's get [ __ ] back organized
because uh you know because people have
things that they need it you know people
are missing regular things people are
missing their birthdays they're missing
this and I was thinking what imagine
some kids miss prom this year imagine
that imagine you're in senior year of
high school and they don't have it that
would not a sucked my senior year this
was it man
this was you were gonna get off and
everything was gonna happen he was gonna
maybe get a little Teddy or something
from your girl Veronica or whatever
whatever you know ver Angela whatever
your girl's name was Keisha whoever
whoever copy you know whoever's letting
loose that evening tit that little baby
milk jug that was gonna let you touch
you know what I'm sayin people had plans
okay I'm gonna get it you know I'm gonna
I'm gonna do well on basketball I'm
gonna get my scholarship people had
plans what about prom
think of all the high school seniors are
not getting to go to prom this year nope
do prom was it prom we member prom man
now you can't how you gonna do what are
you even gonna do you're gonna order a
prom you can do Amazon prom
you're gonna get you gonna do an Amazon
prominent gonna bring you a little it's
just a little box and they got a you
know they got a bunch of liquor in there
and you and you have to drink it real
early and then listen to some music that
you don't remember and then they just
they also in there there's a picture of
you just and it's just you got a vomit
in your buddy's car and then they
already put the picture a picture
together if you just passed out and your
girlfriend's driving you home cuz you
passed out in the back because your boy
Lance gave you a couple hits a badass at
bra a couple bootleg shitty with his
cousin made man that little [ __ ]
paper mache you know kaleidoscope
starter it's just I don't know just a
mad but yeah it's like you think about
all the things you were that could be
affected and that are being affected
there's a you know there's just it's
it's so interesting I mean all the
different down to the minutiae of things
the little things
somebody had a trip planned to uh engage
themselves to get engaged to someone
asking to marry to do family start fam
you know and now that's been postponed
okay our trip I don't know do I still
and now we're fighting and now with the
and now we might not even be together
what the hell what the hell Sharlee Sh
we was supposed to if this was gonna be
something we was going to bar/bat us you
know we had two first-class tickets to
Barbados and we was gonna be lovers you
know and now we [ __ ] fighting so it's
just it's interesting man
it's interesting and also it's
interesting how many things we expect
you know how much I expected I expected
things to be the same oh I didn't
realize I was living in and in this
system of like of needs and once I was
you know this human created Cosmo of
society and now it's mother nature plate
you ever played uno and mother nature
just plays that uh what does it call
skip-bo yeah I think it's let me see
what it's called skip-bo yeah remember
that skip-bo I think it was like uno or
something and but then somebody play
skip-bo in a whole [ __ ] changed whatever
plans you had I'm gonna do three of a
kind seven of a kind I'm gonna touch
somebody's ass when the power goes out
and then steal a couple cards and cheat
people had plans but mints and then
somebody played skip-bo or it was in the
deck now what now what and you find out
somebody's been touching your ass now
what and that's what we're doing mother
nature said hey you didn't see I got
this card you didn't see that I that
there's you living out here on my titty
on my belly y'all been out here doing
this and doing NASCAR and doing all you
know hedge funds and [ __ ] threesomes
and all of that y'all doing that on my
ass on my backside on my front side on
my side side and suddenly man there's
some realism hmm okay there's somebody
else playing ball here there's something
else at work
that's nature man it's fascinating
really
but the levels the levels of people that
people are dealing with this at and the
different things and and how people are
handling it it's all pretty fascinating
I think it's really fascinating honestly
nothing is very fascinating uh let's
take another call right here that came
in but first I want to let you know that
bespoke post just sent me a beautiful
traveling bag you know traveling is
something that has been around since the
beginning of time if you read even into
the Bible or into or hieroglyphics or
anything just a book somebody wrote you
know thousands of years ago on the left
on the ground or something or even if
you just put a pick pick up a seashell
from you know the 1300s and listen to
that bastard
you will hear you you will hear a tale
of of times that were different and what
am I talking about and the tale I want
to tell you about is bespoke post you
can start a new routine to upgrade your
everyday life with a monthly box of
awesome from bespoke post they sent me
this beautiful really bag if you want to
do art or you're a doctor you know a
professional stylist looking clutch for
a male or a female but very it has a
masculine feel it did to me so whether
you're looking to commemorate an
occasion with a champagne saber or toast
perfectly aged winter cocktails bespoke
post sends guys only the best stuff
every month this box of awesome has you
covered from style and grooming goods to
bar we're cooking tools and outdoor gear
box of awesome from bespoke post has
carefully built collections for every
part of your life so if you have a part
of your life that could be missing
something
bespoke post is serving that yeah the
latest box I got to get this this
beautiful this beautiful carrying case
it's a bag it's like a it's a traveling
bag for a man for a confident male and
it had kind of a canvas siding and these
leather straps on top beautiful make me
look like I'm a
like I felt like a doctor and like the
17 like the 1975 to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome calm they
released new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories it's free to
sign up and you can skip a month or
cancel anytime
each box costs only 45 bucks but as on
as has over 70 dollars worth of gear
inside get $20 off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of awesome
dot-com and enter code théo th e o at
checkout that's box of awesome dot-com
code th e o for 20% off your first box
bespoke post box of awesome check it out
today's episode I got to let you guys
know is brought to you by Power dots and
you can see here on the youtubes and I
got this beautiful accoutrement for
health
that's what power dot is it puts a
modern spin on clinically proven muscle
stimulation it's the world's smartest
muscle recovery and performance tool you
know a lot of times you'll go if you
have to go to a physical therapist to
get that stem that stimulation and call
it stem over there and they wrap a hot
towel around your head and in an
electric you chill a little bit it's
almost like Guantanamo Bay but power dot
man they handle it differently you know
being fit and healthy is the goal but
being sore or in pain from workouts
that's not the goal so you could spend a
ton of money to hire a personal masseuse
or you could do what I did and check out
power dots and I'm showing you here I
got it on me the first of its kind power
dot is built around an intuitive mobile
app that provides the user with preset
programs designed to speed up your
recovery improve athletic performance
reduce pain and rehab from injury the
app guides you through the process with
pre designed programs like massage and
pad placement photos for places like
your lower back now to be able to treat
yourself you know we live in a lot more
DIY society especially these days and
power dot is exactly that you know you
can't get out to the place you
need to go for your usual stimulation or
your physical therapy take care of it
yourself
take responsibility travelling with
power dog is extremely convenient and
it's used by the best in the world
athletes throughout the NFL MLB NHL and
MLS as well as Tour de France cyclists
and CrossFit athletes I gotta let you
know also that this past weekend
listeners powered out is offering our
customers a free 30-day trial plus an
additional 20% off that's right
power dot is offering our us customers a
free 30 day trial plus an additional 20
percent off go to power dot powr do
t.com slash th EO and use the code Theo
at checkout for 20% off your order
that's power dot-com slash Theo and use
the code Theo at checkout for 20% off
your order
it's so manageable connects to an app on
your phone take care of yourself help
yourself recover it's DIY man thank you
and now back to the episode like this
mm-hmm
that goes let's take this call man here
we go hey Theo this is Steve from Reis
Prairie Missouri what's up Steve east
Missouri man and I ended up out there
and legatee Isaac's and I was supposed
to be doing comedy and they didn't tell
the motel we were staying at and they
had rented the thing out to a damn um
you know that little touching festival
swingers bunch a real thick swingers bro
bunch of damn people just Sun burn
victims bra a bunch of real [ __ ]
gristle brothers and sisters you know
kind of people it'll just kind of sip
this you know just really just sip the
uh the kind of people that after a bacon
plate is empty they'll take one and
we'll take the plate off and just kind
of sip sip off or whatever it left in a
base of that plea you know you know some
real bacon separates anyway on where
brother yeah
I just want to let you know that I'm
watching this past weekend tonight
Monday March 24th you asked her opinion
on the coronavirus and I wanted to let
you know that it has affected my life
son because work has slowed down a lot
people are worried about getting laid
off but at the same time people worried
about getting laid - damn I'll tell you
coronaviruses locked up all of the wasps
a and we NER that there ever was man
JC bruh JC to the max dog Jesus fries
homeward but were you talking about
brother I'm I'm not scared because I
have you on this past weekend I'm sorry
man I'm gonna go back on your call
because I interrupted it kind of with
being perverse really honestly man so
let's go again
first and I wanted to let you know that
it has affected my life son because work
is slowed down a lot people are worried
about these laid off but at the same
time I'm not scared because I have you
on this past weekend and King and sting
and everything's been going good as far
as I can no because my kids are gonna be
taken care of and everything's just good
I mean I'm gonna interrupt you man but
because this or you know when you say
your kids are gonna be taken care of
that's oh this is something that a lot
of people aren't saying you know I see a
lot of people right now blame in the
government our government we don't have
enough masks we don't have enough masks
boy
well what if nobody knew this was gonna
happen people say well they knew and
listen net and here's the thing if you
have children if you have yourself
that's your responsibility the
government it's not the gun the
government is just people it's our
responsibility to take care of ourselves
the government is just a little is just
a severe an intricate stack of systems
that's all it is run by people human
beings you don't have so your kid
doesn't have a mask you don't have
enough food stuff at the house that's
your fault I don't have bottled water I
don't have a kool-aid powder you know
what I'm saying I don't have a sack of
almonds or a sack of um hazelnuts that's
my fault oh there's not gonna be masks
for our kids there's not that if you're
a parent that's your fault it's not the
government's responsibility to take care
of you you had children
you need to have [ __ ] at the house in
case they're hungry I'll just add this
bowl I get just people share all of
these this man you don't owe they ain't
even got the damn uh much my boy lo uh
little Derrick ya ain't even had a
biscuit in a month well [ __ ] get him
a biscuit then you know I know that
there are like um I know that like you
know people run out of money I'm not
trying to be insensitive to that I know
that you know that people don't have
unlimited that people don't have
unlimited what does it call when you
things like a group of things P
resources I know that but if we're not
it we have to be prepared for life I
think that's it we're I think we're
really lucky right now a lot of us are
getting a learning lesson like I don't
you know I don't have children and this
and that but if I don't if I'm not
prepared that's my fault you know I just
get it just the finger-pointing to me
just really and in the news channels too
you know I don't watch a lot of the news
I see some of it on my phone and I'll
put the apps on and take them off but
and on Twitter just it's like wow the if
you've the second you start expecting
the government to take care of you
you've already lost cat daddy
so yeah just like what I'm saying is and
I need to be more constructive here even
for myself it's our responsibility if
you have a child and your child does it
you know something goes down and you
can't you you don't have something for
your kid what are you gonna look in your
kids eyes your kids like that dad what a
dad you're gonna tell you kid all the
government to govern man no you you're
the government for your child you're
your child's government so you rave you
Abe Lincoln in your house so you gotta
tighten up you know in - sorry I didn't
mean to jump on but this [ __ ] got me
fired that ship just man it boils my it
boils my beef bruh it just boils my beef
man when everybody they you know they
should have people should do why didn't
we we should have done this well I'm
telling you we're doing now it's are you
as a human I'm not gonna lay there on my
deathbed like oh man the government
didn't they didn't have enough mass for
this or that I they didn't have enough
oh they didn't I didn't get that bag of
oatmeal from them
well well bruh get you out meal
this is a practice run for everybody if
[ __ ] got really really wild
if the interstate turns into a damn
waterslide it could get wild man so I'm
just saying this is your your kids
government's all responsibility man I'm
rambling but you know what you feel what
I'm saying I just don't like that extra
blame [ __ ] man I just don't like it
and I know that I'm not saying people
don't need to be subsidized and it's not
helpful and this is a great time to help
each other but you know just that man
brought it up that you know he is
fortunately you feelin okay and you know
his kids are okay and we have to be our
own governments as well you know this is
teaching me I have to prepare I have to
have the things in place that I need and
I'm grateful that there's this grace
period of time when things are
comfortable enough to gut the there's
still enough money where there's still
enough of a government can give people
money and we're really fortunate right
now you know I don't know if this is
happening in every country around the
world but I know that in America right
now that the government is saying hey
we're gonna mail you some money man I'm
pretty fortunate I need to work on my
gratitude man you got I mean to get all
just [ __ ] got me bent up but anybody
could get it okay
oh I can rollerskate you know my dad
used to roller skate I can't get it you
could get it wheels all right you could
get it out there and who the [ __ ] is
still rollerskating bro you could get it
man I'll tell you this something I've
been doing at the house is uh you know
how crazy is it they're just being at
home suddenly I'm like a chef I'm doing
Luda I got julienne carrots over here I
got a half of a [ __ ] Filipino back
strap over there grilling on the UM on
the broiler plate I got I'm making
caramel sauce I'm doing this I'm looking
up recipes
I got monk fruit sugars I'm doing
everything I don't even know what was
going on dude the only recipe I've even
had for the past couple years that
almond butter right out the jar into the
old front hole brother that was my one
of my fancier recipes but now I'm doing
it all I got a couple of got a little
bit of um you know I got a steak steak
shank and I'll shank that [ __ ] up you
know what I'm saying I got one of those
kind of kill its yourself kits where
they send you to meet and you get to
stab it a few more times and then it
shows you how to defer it and Grill it
you know they got all kind of ways you
can get your stuff now but if you want
to do this they got it you know what I'm
saying I'm over here slicing up garlic
I'm over here I got half a thing of
Copenhagen in the skillet and another in
a quarter of a zen and my joy in my jaw
and i'm doing different stuff you know
suddenly I'm [ __ ] Chef Boyardee em
bro he's good so all right let's take
another call here that came in
here we go hey what I'm CEO and the
whole this past weekend gang this is
Matt from Fort Worth and what's up Matt
from Fort Worth thank you for calling
brother homeward I was calling code in
your podcast I just heard you were
asking how we're doing in the rest of
America throughout all this virus
shenanigan and I just wanted to say it's
really not that bad like I work in metal
recycling serving the public all day I'm
handling people's driver's license I'm
shooting the [ __ ] with them on the
loading dock and you know all they do is
run around junkyard the junkyard buying
stuff I think it's time for you to apply
for - take it from anyways the whole
thing is I've been in direct contact
with people non-stop strangers all the
time for weeks and months ever since it
started and I'm not sick I got a little
baby who's five months old at home I
haven't transmitted any disease the
earth okay there you go right there
metal Matt and he's working over there
at the aluminum factory and I used to do
man and I remember your kind Matt I've
been around you guys because I used to
ride my bike on the weekends and I would
go get cans and anything metal you know
I used to try a wagon up behind my bike
me and my boy Summerall bro and he had
some mom you know r.i.p bruh he's not
dead but he's you know he never really
was like a hundred percent alive even
when I met him as a as a child but he um
we used to tie a wheelbarrow the two
back you know the prongs of a
wheelbarrow we would tie each one to the
back of our bike so the wheelbarrow was
facing the other way and we would double
we were both bike and we'd go all around
stacking cans getting getting cans from
in the woods everywhere
any type of metal can anything that was
metal [ __ ] half a baby crib bruh you
know what I'm saying cut off the bottom
leave the baby sitting there and the
wheels and [ __ ] the metal parts take
that you know anything that was metal do
we get over about a school and sometimes
at the bottom of the doors at school
they'd have these metal plates on the
door and you could pry those off
and we throw those in there and we'd
roll over to the aluminum it would take
us three days have a stack of cans man
all kinds of metals in there you know
all kind of anything that was metal you
know little statues of little [ __ ]
you know they'd have a little statue of
a [ __ ] uh sherwin-williams or a
little statue of um you know Harry
Connick jr. you know of one that was
made out of pure metal and we take that
[ __ ] and roll it over there and we roll
up dude we were so tired we could barely
move that bike man barely just my thighs
were just pumping just sexy just god
damn bruh look like just two beautiful
[ __ ] turkey legs that a king would
eat and we get that bike over there to
the aluminum and it was just a basically
a van like somebody had a van and I said
we buy metal and had a scale out there
and we put that [ __ ] on the scale and
they would give us about my own damn
probably 45 cents I almost killed myself
dude trying to get all that [ __ ] so I
know you're kind man but yeah you guys
are good people and and I'm glad y'all
are doing well man I'm glad you guys are
doing well yes so it's this that's what
I'm saying this is that hiding go seek
disease man and some people are getting
it and some people are not man so it's
definitely been interesting I do want to
call a guy you know and I was thinking
about this the other day and and and a
lot of listeners reached out sorry I got
it relax a little getting kind of
excited
wait Rick long Mickey and you know
everybody knows Mickey man he got those
new air sacks he got those Oh to sip
hitters you know them in her tits bruh
those wet markets bro
you know what I'm talking about lungs
those [ __ ] ribcage wet markets and he
got um and he had a rare disorder and
he's been a part of this program for
maybe a year and a half two years now
but I wanted to check in with Mickey and
see how he's doing in this time and I
think that that could give us all a
little bit of insight into what some
people's lives are like so gang let me
call them right now look Mickey do it
man what's up man thank you for uh
thanks for answering the phone man how
are you man I've been doing good dude
I've been doing good I've been on the
road actually from my house for the past
three weeks and actually today was first
back home first back day home because
mom was actually out mcruiz about four
weeks ago so I'd uh I'd imagine hearing
I tell it album right if she had Corona
man oh your mother was on a cruise ship
yeah about four weeks ago when this all
happened and you know that was during
like while she was on the cruise ship
that's when it actually got registered
as I was like all those ships were being
held up at port and so it was not a good
time to be around when she got back and
she knew and understood that so she okay
with that you know wow man yeah I know
we were texting just the other day about
about jumping on the phone and um yeah I
didn't know that
so so when she came home were you able
to just like easily spend time with her
or how how rare is this for you because
you know just catching up some of our
listeners on you know you had a lung
transplant so do did your doctors tell
you
you have to be more careful like what is
sort of the UM the suggestions that you
get yeah absolutely man uh basically
it's kind of weird like it's back then
about three or four weeks ago is really
conclusive is just general boilerplate
and it's like you know always wear masks
we I have this mass that I was wearing
you know be walk your hands try not to
touch a face you know don't don't be in
large large groups of people you know
and in this case though is kind of like
you know if my mom visit then I can't
even live with so or to be as diligent
as possible I basically have been
staying for these past three weeks like
everybody's hotels yeah so on your
Instagram there was a picture might have
been I think it was Instagram yeah
there's a picture of you like it or a
video is you just getting to a place or
leave in a place so you just been on the
run because you had to stay away from
your mom just in case you was exposed
yeah that's right man and I know that a
lot of people would think like man you
don't want you kick it a friend or
something and what's really interesting
about that and this is nothing gets my
friends but I think you can understand
this feel with your sister it's like a
lot of people in general are just not
very health conscious and that's not
their fault but if I live with anybody
it means that they then inherently have
to take on my same living habits you
know for them it might be okay that they
go to the grocery store but for me it's
not right now
Wow yeah that it is really wild um yeah
so it's like you have to live with
somebody or everyone really does like
has to live with somebody who their
behaviors are gonna or exactly what your
behaviors are or at least our behaviors
that you are comfortable with I think so
yeah and being I think that elderly
especially and I mean definitely
immunosuppressed and for sure with a
long issue it's just the fact that man
like I haven't there were there were
days when I was in these B and B's and I
didn't even see a person you know I
would just I go walk in a park or
something but
I did I wouldn't even see people just
extreme isolation and you're a real
social guy man I mean that but do you
feel like that was kind of bumming you
out socially like outside of like you
know like you know having to be probably
a more health-conscious than the rest of
us just you know because of your immune
system we were you feeling like a social
depression at all oh absolutely man yeah
I mean yesterday yeah yeah it was
yesterday when I got back to my house
and I was driving and literally
listening to my own music the Sun was
out and I was already getting just feels
so good and just to even be out out of
the house and stuff so absolutely it but
you know what it gives me I don't need
to be cliche but it really gives me a
lot of perspective again where I'm like
man I I get to go back home and I was
just really excited about that and you
know the amount of perspective that I
feel like it gives and I think it gives
all of us after this is all done and I
think that we will at least for a time
the first few times first couple weeks
yeah be like man we've made it through
and now I gotta be with my friends and
you know it sounds weird it's like I get
to work yeah it's something that people
don't want to do typically or you know
we got a break you know we got to make
money to get bread and everything but
you know now it's gonna be like I
actually get to be able to do that
because there's just so many people out
there that's really they're really
suffering yeah man that's man that's a
great point dude yeah a lot of people
it's like I think yeah I think it if if
we look at it the right way then it's
really a great opportunity to say man I
get to do these things I get to see my
mom you know I get to you know go
fishing with my friend I get to go to
work today you know I get to go and even
if my job isn't my favorite job like I
get to go do it yeah oh absolutely man
and you know I have I have a friend who
he was in Disneyland when this all
happened Ryan got it got cancelled and
you know he posted on be a guy or not a
lot cuz understand I got all my gay
friends no joke dude they [ __ ] all
been talking about Disneyland it's all
days it's like constantly I'm like
the [ __ ] chill bro that's hilarious
man but yeah so he was over there in you
know a night I saw him make this
Facebook post where he was like man it's
another gonna be another two two months
of this or something I'm gonna drive
driven crazy and I just told him I was
like man you know just try to think for
a second like boredom is that the least
of your concerns right now if you really
think about it again like have some
perspective man it's you are in
Disneyland bro like that's as good as it
gets
you know like you sure you're crazy what
are you talking about but you and you
said that it protects you yesterday
you're like you'd imagine if you you've
been on a transplant list for years or
months or whatever and you'll find out
at the opportunity and then this happens
and it's secondary to the national
crisis that's god it's so it would seem
so abysmal right and at the same time
again it's just - I don't want to sound
cliche as always but man yeah I I called
my dad everyday you know my dad elderly
easy he's 80 you know I'm like I just
hope and hoping things don't take him I
call him every day I try to try to call
my loved ones and tell him I love him
and I got a friend right now he went
into the ER he lives in Detroit
you met him briefly my best friend Sammy
oh yeah man and when you guys at the
comedy club yeah yeah that's right man
and so anyways he you know he went in
for a cast can today they think that he
might have miles Kovac it's like this is
hitting a lot of people you know just
got to tell him you love them yeah yeah
man well you've always been really like
a kind of like a perspective gadget bro
if you were like a cartoon character I
think it would be perspective gadget
dude
Mickey man thanks so much for being
supportive and everything and we got to
get you in here next time you're in town
and uh and sit and chat and and again
man thank you so much dude and be safe
and and let's stay in touch
I'd love that see all right man much
love dude all right gang bro all right
Wow interesting you know he be had
because he had Mickey had cystic
fibrosis in his lungs and that's when
you have just bad lungs and this you
know really you don't even you
his lungs if you look back at some of
our old episodes and stuff he really had
a tough go of it but he you know he was
on the transplant list and he got them
bags and and he really got tightened up
and so I you know he really is a beacon
of perspective because he's been at
literally loitering at death's doorstep
before you know he'd been a member then
people that come to your house to sell
magazines or something
hey we got these magazines you need
outdoor life you need uh fishing only
you know what I'm saying you need
[ __ ] Star Wars magazine monthly get
it while it's hot and he was like he was
like met the magazine man on death's
doorstep just milling around out there
so and so we're grateful that uh that he
answered our call I'd give you some tour
dates of I don't have any it's because
nobody has any that's why you know we
had that uh that's show in which a
McCall it had got canceled and that was
in Nashville and we'll figure it out in
the future I want to let you know right
now about better help this episode is
brought to you by better help and better
help is that you know it's which what it
is man is a tough time if you need some
counseling you need somebody to talk to
you need a lover you need somebody with
ears and a heart then better help can
help better help will assess your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating with your therapist in
under 24 hours so it really is it's
almost an emergency care you know it's
not a crisis line and it's not self help
but is professional counseling done
securely online there's a broad range of
expertise in better helps counselor
network which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide you know
I've talked about my experience on it
and better help in a wild you know you
all them you could text them you get on
there it's pretty easy and you figure
out okay how do I get a therapist and
next thing you know they call you Dianna
gives you a ring or they match you up
with Anthony or crease the ball or
whoever and you have a therapist and you
see how you communicate with them do you
do it over text do you do it over voice
do you do it over video it's affordable
more affordable than traditional offline
counseling and better help want you to
start living a happier life today right
now you can visit better help.com slash
Theo th e oh that's better h e LP and
join the over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
special offer for this past weekend
listeners you get 10% off your first
month at better help calm slash Theo all
right let's get into another call here
hey Kenneth over here in Gainesville
Georgia people don't even know that
that's a place and it is homework and I
just got some some life advice questions
right now you know um right now I'm
working at Domino's as a delivery driver
oh yeah and I do enjoy the Domino's um
they're uh thin crust more and I feel
like an absolute bum I'm 19 years old
and I feel like I'm not doing anything
with my life
you know I tried to go to college for
performing arts honestly I didn't get my
thoughts together before I tried to
leave this message I'm gonna call back
and try again later well that's okay man
you know what man I don't think any call
has ever reminded me more of myself man
than this one you know you call you
don't have a plan and you get there and
you realize you don't have a plan and
you just you didn't give up that you
said I'll call again you
No and all and not just that this stuff
too you know Mickey just touched on it
trickling Mickey with those [ __ ] new
enter hitters got he got verbal on this
Teddy he said that you know it's a
prospective time now you get to do
something now before if you did magic
everybody's like oh look at this [ __ ]
you know with that little bit of hand
hide-and-go-seek he's doing this dude is
really just a burglar bryce stealing
[ __ ] but the truth is he does magic
but before people talking [ __ ] but now
maybe them now the magician says hey I
get to I do magic you know now people
are gonna come out of this roaring out
of the cave you know we were all a
tapper before I don't really care about
my I don't know what I'd do there's no
now we're with a purpose you feel me
that worked out well you know I'm saying
we come out with a roar so yeah you a
delivery guy man you run in hot pie you
run in hot pie brother not anybody could
do that
don't don't don't think you're not
special
cuz you over there slinging hp's bro
people want you always around do you the
total opposite of the police bro
people always welcome you with that 12
inch that's 16 inch bra with that you
know the side thing of cinnamon tots
daddy you know you have you you but you
but you're also no matter what you do
when you show up you if you show up with
that purpose be that back be a
performing artist pie guy show up with
that pie and delivered a rap be little
slice bread dirty slice you know what
I'm saying a little sauce be [ __ ]
little long you know a little nasty a
little anchovy or medium bruh be medium
but I'm saying is you you know what I'm
saying you you show up and in if you get
like a you get a side skill or something
ready for yourself
say you and learn a rat learn a riddle
knock knock who's there bro damn dog
meat lovers son you know what I'm saying
Punk you know what I'm saying feel
yourself ill your ham with sausage and
punch yourself in the [ __ ] face bro
what I'm saying is have a plan yeah you
just deliver them pie but it's still you
showing up yeah you're behind the pizza
you might deliver something too damn
whoever you might get your veneer in
Atlanta you might deliver some [ __ ] too
freaking um Evander Holyfield you might
deliver some [ __ ] to little um little uh
you know little Khalifa or whatever and
he might say oh I love this guy no make
sure it's just the poppy you you're
showing up with I don't care what it is
you know we gotta remember that yeah I
bring humor sometimes and [ __ ] kind
of Kleenex as well a lot of other times
but still it's me the person that shows
up with whatever I'm bringing you know
it's the you know that yeah the waitress
brings your food but a lot of times the
food's only gonna get me so far there's
a human on the other end of that arm on
the other end of that hand that just
dropped that plate off at my table and
that person I might they're there could
be a lifelong relationship or connection
there whereas the the relationship I'm
gonna have with this food is gonna be
brief I'm not preaching at you man I'm
just saying you know you don't know
sometimes where the path that you're on
is gonna lead you and you also don't
notice like I remember I quit comedy I
didn't quit but I just I kind of just
well I was in love with the girl back at
home and I went home I wasn't I mean I
was in love but I also was just in I was
afraid that she was banging other people
and I got scared
and I went back there to Louisiana and I
was tending bar at a Mexican restaurant
and I broke a damn margarita machine I
only worked three shifts or actually
probably worked about 30 shifts and I
broke up [ __ ] more
reader machine that probably cost about
$1,800 and I still feel bad about that
but um and I think I probably lied about
I didn't lie about it but I put all the
parts back in there and just kind of
pretended like they liked it still
worked was okay or something but but
what I'm what I'm trying to say is man
you know it took something you know I
worked there it was fine and they had
stages in New Orleans and I got up on
stages in New Orleans and I didn't think
I was gonna keep doing comedy but I kept
doing it and and eventually you know I
ended up back out here in Los Angeles
and it was only for about six months
that I was there but but I didn't know
exactly at the time so you got into
performing arts you weren't sure right
now you you know you perform in pies you
sling in circle [ __ ] snacks man
you're fine you're gonna be okay but you
don't know if in the future you next
thing you know what I'm saying you might
start a business with the Performing pie
guys well you'd uh each pie comes with a
performance dude I would love that I
would love to know that whoever is
bringing my pie for an extra $10 I'm
about to get that that audio [ __ ]
that dance concept hitter you know you
might be that and what I'm saying is it
takes these elements it takes these
things you know it takes the world to
set these these things on your scale
like okay you could you know I need you
to be doing pies I need you to you know
try school performing arts but that
doesn't work and I need this and and
then eventually you see what the world
is put on your plate and say oh okay I'm
gonna put these things together and this
is gonna be what I'm gonna serve you
know and Plus right now posts mate
they're the hottest people in the land
people want to talk about the front
lines of Surgeons and something somebody
carving into somebody's ass to get a
damn a giblet or something but the real
hitters out there or post mates people
you got a guy you know what I'm saying
elbow crawling up to your front door
risk in his long life just
so you could have a damn uh um you know
three enchiladas with no cheese on them
you got a little urban girl out there
little char ket and she got you know
what I'm saying she's [ __ ] down there
she wearing a football helmet to fight
the virus and she's out there and she
rollin up in the arm dodge you know what
I'm saying and she [ __ ] humming a
couple of damn you know cinnamon
hotcakes out of her car out that side
window bro just trying to make $11
trying to make six dollars risking her
life so you could have a little morning
snack I mean these are the real front
liners people doing food delivery you
got a guy over here he don't even he
wrapped his whole car in visqueen he
can't even read he don't even have a
driver's license and he's over here and
he and he's uh he's grilling chilaquiles
in the backseat and he sets he sets it
on the hood of his car and then he
drives the car right up to you how front
door and you reach out there and leave
him you know what seven dollars on the
front on the hood they put it under the
hood I'll get it later all right
my prior you know you got a dude he
don't even have a car he works for post
mates bruh he worked for post maybe this
dude you don't even know if he's gonna
[ __ ] show up you ever got that dude
you know what I'm saying it's [ __ ]
9:15 p.m. he tells you a little Anthony
he tells you he's on his way
next thing you notice dudes on a damn
[ __ ] bird scooter or something he's
on that [ __ ] nine speed bruh and he
got a damn off you know he got a half a
cup of soup under his own trying to get
it to you trying to serve up a little
minestrone for you because he cares
about you I mean these are the front
line workers people we got to take care
of each other that's all I'm saying
um what else do we have man what else do
we have
let me take a call here that came in
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three what's up Justin calling from
Tennessee man thank you for calling in
our IP past summit you know what I'm
saying one of the [ __ ] most gangsta
lesbians in the game bro one mm straight
games was banging out them Winston's
freaking died right after she quit
playing bro retired bro
gang [ __ ] on we're brother I'm a yes and
and us you know how we were feeling
about this
Rhona deal on the podcast man I think
I'm kind of like you man I just ain't
really worried about it you know I got
it I got a two-year-old I got another
little baby girl coming in ah you know
it is what it is
can I feel like a damn superhero out
here man understand you know just ninja
shot from the [ __ ] out of the sky
everybody looked at me cuz everybody
shut down in my hometown you know if you
like man do this damn take your fighters
in all Browns coming out here at
delivering my stuff I mean I don't know
it makes me feel good you know I ain't
gonna let it big things see that looks
right now you feel me I'm gonna let it
hold me down yeah it's cool man you know
everything's all good gotta say 5-0
something on the side gang brah I love
that man I love your attitude yeah I'm
not gonna let it beat me you know that's
a decision you can make easily people
want to lay down people wanna blame the
point this fan but do it or how are you
prepared are you gonna let it beat you
that's the thing because if you're gonna
let it if you've already decided that
you that that's an option for it to beat
you
then it'll find and something will find
a way if fittings if it aint Corona it's
something something else will get find a
way to get you you've already decided in
your head I love it man you guys are
Cape Crusaders dude I'm not joking I saw
the UPS guy yesterday it out dude he was
blasting some [ __ ] Travis Scott he
was living it and I was like dang man
this dude is a legend this dude is out
here like Book of Eli out here
this guy's like 5 hole goes west they
out here man so gang man you stay brave
man and stay out there and um and thank
you for calling man thank you for
calling brother let's take a call right
here that came in ninety five six six
four nine five zero three well I just
wanted to give you a call
love the podcast just wanted to give you
you know ask you a question during this
time of the Rona you trapped inside not
going out too much and I know usually
you get your inspiration from everyday
events I was wondering how you get the
inspiration now and if you're all
writing during your time of Solitude and
how difficult is it for you to actually
get that inspiration and come up with
ideas so no I know that [ __ ] can be
difficult to pop and stuff at us you
know so dang brother yeah I agree man it
can be difficult and where's my
inspiration coming from you know I'm
feeling right now I'm not really trying
to think of funny jokes I'm just trying
to take care of myself you know I am I'm
trying to take care of myself
I'm 35 days off of cigarettes so thank
God for that right now so I'm feeling
grateful for that you know I'm been
doing yoga I started seeing a
chiropractic and I'm just trying to
relax man I'm trying to get some
perspective back in my life I'm trying
to get some gratitude
you know I need those things
and I've really had lost over the past
six nine months I just had lost a lot of
them I didn't mean to I just was so busy
I didn't have any it was hard to grasp
my own life you know and here I was
living my dreams and I'm just hard to
grasp it so I'm grateful to have this
time for a little bit of reflection
I'm grateful right now that I can put
food on my table and I can uh you know I
know I can pay my rent next month you
know I'm grateful that I have I know
there's people that love me and I know I
can care about him and I can reach out
and that's the only things I'm thinking
about right now I've been doing some
yoga by myself you know it's been a good
time for me to find things to put back
on my own plate like I used to love
going to the gym for myself I wasn't
doing it to like you know really look I
saw I was just doing it because I loved
it and I think overall with a lot of
things I was burnt out you know I
haven't even felt like getting onstage I
haven't felt like being on stage for a
while I haven't been up to the Comedy
Store even before I'd only been there
about two or three nights in about three
months before it was closed because I
was working out of town so much and and
I just was tired so you know I'm I'm
trying to I'm doing meditation I'm doing
15 moments I'm almost up to 15 minutes
of meditation per day so and I'm working
in stronger on trying to focus more on
my a program and that's what I'm doing
I've been rolling my body out brother
that's been a new thing using that foam
roller like everywhere Braun talking
roll in the front of my arms the side
like things that hurt rolling my chest
out I mean I can put my arm almost kind
of straight so those have been things
that I've been doing man to stay busy
and stay uh just kind of stay that like
my inspiration will come if I take care
of myself and I hadn't felt like I've
been taking care of myself for a while
so yeah I'm just trying to find the joys
in this the little joys
all right let's so let's take another
call that came on here gang brother
video this is your boy do you nut from
Grand Rapids are you gonna catch a lot
of flack for that
what's up Dee let's here baby gang
homework I just wanted to say I really
appreciated the way you've been stepping
up your game with the podcasts over
these hard times and it's always good to
hear your voice oh thanks man that's
nice you to say that man you know I'm
trying to feel good and I'm trying and I
yeah I love it when I you know I get
these voicemails and people calling and
we get to see what's going on and you
know I do feel a sense of connection man
and I really man I'm glad you said that
because I needed to hear that I'm
grateful for that homework but I got a
question for you what are people doing
to stay connected to their support
groups during these hard times and
stresses off and we're out here fighting
to stay sober and I got a call last week
and they said that all of my meetings
were canceled so I'm a leader at
celebrate recovery and I was like well
we can't have that so I got some of the
guys together over a phone call and we
had a meeting and it turned out really
well but I just wondering what other
people are doing they connected thanks
for the question man I was fixing my
hair there as well while I was listening
but I was listening um you know a lot of
recovery groups seem to be doing zoom
meetings right now and zoom has really
really taken off people are using that
as a forum to come to connect for
everything talking to family you know
and specifically for recovery you know
I've gotten a lot of messages and dm's
from people that are struggling and
thank you for those and I'm you know I'm
trying to share it my just my experience
and I'm trying to stay sober myself and
you know we do what we can and uh but
you know it's easier for me to say oh
the zoom meetings are dumb or they're
not the same and that's fine it's easy
for me to say anything is dumb but
but I believe that if you feel if you
were if you want something to work for
you it will work for you so a lot of it
again is just going down in perspective
and so that's all I'm doing man is going
to some zoom meetings I'm keeping in
touch with other guys and trying to stay
out of the headspace of oh this these
programs don't work this stuff doesn't
work oh here's an excuse err and it's
hard man
it's been hard getting in our struggle
recently was just looking at escorts and
pornography that cut that stuff really
snuck back into me about maybe a couple
weeks ago and uh and so I that's one
thing that's been tough because um it's
just so much idle time it's almost time
by yourself
and so you know I'm hoping to start you
maybe go to some new type of meetings
and stuff or I got to get a new blocker
on my phone because pornography I
noticed for me is the biggest catalyst
for other other things once I start
looking at porn then I'll start it just
makes me want to do all kind of trouble
you know me want to break in the
building or do a cocaine or something
you know or do uh you know or see
somebody's ass or something that I don't
know so that's you know I noticed really
that is such a catalyst for other things
so that's something I got to make sure I
nip out of my butt
bud nip out of my butt immediately but
the eff bro man I'm I'm happy to be here
today oh and one other thing I want to
say one cool thing about zoom meetings
with recovery right now is you can go to
ones in different cities and states so
if you live in New Orleans you could go
to a meeting in you could go to the
Bread and Roses meeting on Saturday at
10:30 a.m. in Los Angeles which is a
really popular and famous and
interesting meeting you could go to a
fan Atlantic group meeting in in New
York City so there's really some you
know if you are in a small place or
something and you don't know about
recovery suddenly or you ever haven't
been
recovery meetings or something you can
suddenly be in them in a meeting with
that may have different speakers and
real fancy you know polished well
speakers in them so that's amazing today
and that's that's what that's one of the
gifts of right now is this zoom boom
gang all right we're going to do a
patreon question that came in and we
changed patreon this week you can check
it out if you want you can go to the
patreon and check it out
and I want to thank all of our
supporters and one of the questions that
came in this is from Dini what's up do
Passover is coming up this week I wanted
to know if you ever attended a Passover
Seder or had any Jewish friends gang
gang from Easter al Oh
Thank You Dini and I've never been to
Israel but at least Vail but I've always
wanted to go I've heard really
interesting things about it yeah I oh
yeah my one of my best friends lives
upstairs from me and he is Jewish I
think he's a hundred percent Jewish and
and so his family that has long invited
me over over the past few years within
the past decade even for a different
type of uh yiddish feasts and
get-togethers and you know reading of
religious texts and stuff like that and
great company good times some of the
worst food but but i loved a lot of the
tradition and or just like more simple
I'm from Louisiana so jump from the wind
I'm so yeah some of the food you're just
like damn the saint of food you notice a
damn pickle bruh you know you got you
know you got 19 people do you know
divvying up a pickle as a appetizer i
like come on brah this ain't even but
yeah a lot of good times man some really
really fun times yeah I have a it's it's
crazy especially living out in Los
Angeles you meet a lot of Jays
you get Jade up you know you get a lot
of Jewish friends and so yeah it's crazy
because a lot of my really best friends
out here are Jewish so I've been to some
feasts over the years and it's always
been a blast sometimes you got the
little hat that little the little hair
wallet and uh and yes so I've gotten to
see some of the the environment and in
different Passover in Seder feasts and
the applesauce and the reasons for the
different foods you know they got these
carrots because you know Larry you know
fell DeBerg or whatever you know he Oh
him was died but they had you know he
and his cousin split a carrot or
something or they had you know seven
days of oil but they made it last for 40
days so obviously some of the stuff I'm
regurgitating his hit-or-miss here but
yeah I've had a lot of nice times man
they got and they have a lot of good
holidays throughout the year so the Jews
will throw up some really good holidays
here and there so go enjoy one of those
if somebody invited you over to a seder
and it's a really nice thing if they do
that it's like with them welcoming you
over for like a Christmas meal if you
are in the of the Christian dialect so
thank you for that question Dini if I
ever come to Israel you're gonna have to
show me around you have to show me some
of what it's like over there
I would love to to learn more what else
what else what else what is a piece of
advice this is from Jyothi and this is
on patreon what is a piece of advice
someone gave you that you remember
almost every day um you know my father
told me when I was real little he told
me that I was a survivor that was one of
the only things I really remember him
telling me you know he would always uh
say you're a survivor you know and and I
thought that that was nice
here I think because I don't know if he
knew that I was gonna have a tough time
being a child or whatever you know and I
and sometimes we have a tough time
sometimes our environments tough and
sometimes just the way we interact with
our environment is tough but he told me
I'll be a survivor and I think about
that a lot I thought it was a neat thing
to say because it leaves it vague enough
where I can apply it to a lot of
different things and you can [ __ ] up and
still be a survivor so I thought that
that was pretty neat you know I think a
lot of things like I remember from that
movie the patriot aim small miss small I
think about that a lot that pops in my
head all the time the first time because
because any small miss small it's like
if I can't do something real big what
can I do on al it what can I do on a
level that's realistic and that's
something that I think really applies to
right now - what can I do what can I do
one or level that's realistic you know
yeah I can't do like maybe I can't do
some huge fundraiser to do something
like this to save the world like Bill
Gates or something or you know like the
Patriots owner Robert Kraft they sent
their plane to China and bought a
million cases of mass and flew them back
you know they can do that but what could
I you know and so now there's just
something small it's helping out
somebody it's like just doing what kind
of do something small that I know is
gonna be effective because something's
small that's effective - if it's just to
one person it's huge to them so I think
that the aim small miss small is
something that uh that I remember a lot
and that's not really advice I heard
that in a movie you know my best friend
Scott his dad when I was growing up his
dad told me um well his dad told me to
move to California and trauma dreams out
because he said well you can always
move back he goes and if you look back
down the road you might regret if you
don't and I remembered that but it's a
good question I'm have to think about
what are some things that maybe have
been told to me over the years I watched
also the louis c.k special and actually
watch that this afternoon it it's a it's
hilarious I mean I laughed he surprised
me so many times and if some people like
most people I think enjoy Louis CK's a
comedian you know the man is a pervert
but he also is a comedy man and he can
beat those two things you know there's
not a rule you can only be one thing a
lot of the news they like to make you
think oh you can only be one thing buddy
what are you you a milkman or you um you
know are you somebody that whispers a
lot [ __ ] I could do both you know I'm
saying you could be Bill Cosby is he a
pervert rapist seems like that is the
case he's also very entertaining man you
could be both things Louie CK the
special was hilarious man it was
hilarious you know I've never known
Louie
I cross paths with him twice he always
seemed like a bit of like a real cocky
kind of dude to me but he is there's
it's just at a different level man his
his is is I mean it's [ __ ] good bro
it's [ __ ] good and if I were that
good at comedy dude I would be cocky I
think I mean it is it's just fun it's
also in some parts it's so dark bro it
is dark like it is damn bro I'm
surprised if you looked in there's like
a day I mean it is they could have
filmed black panther during part of it
it's dark bro it is dark
but it's it almost forever he reminds me
of a dis it's almost like this dirty
Shakespeare almost he definitely has his
in such contact with a certain point of
view in his head that it's I mean it's
just baffling and you can never tell if
he thinks that he's because he's always
commenting on himself and I can never
tell if he is amused by himself repulsed
or proud and it's fascinating to not be
able to know that and to listen to him
at the same time you can just you get
this there's this ambiance from him
that's just it's so precisely humanly
vulgar almost in a way or but not just
vulgar it's fat it's it's it's it's
hilarious there's gonna be some dark
stuff if you go in there like oh man um
you know if he's as soon as he says
Native American I'm shutting it off I'm
shutting it off ah you know if you go in
there if using an T for something you
probably won't like this [ __ ] you know
if you spend if you were like a lifetime
CNN watch or kinda or you know if you
buy that own a CNN sweatshirt you
probably won't like it it's just but
it's very honest I felt like it's very
honest to a part of our brain or
something that we want to close or that
society wants to close now
and I just thought it was layers does
that mean that I anything else from me
doesn't mean anything else
me it means that I'm a fewer of his
comedy and that the [ __ ] was [ __ ]
really funny bro and you may have
different takes on it and that's I hope
that you do I hope you have your own
take on it and I would even have to
think about it more I just watched it
but uh but if you're looking for a watch
and it's available on his website and I
you know you know we're not doing any
ads for them or anything or whatever but
but the man is you know any talks about
is you know some of the stuff that
happened and stuff it's interesting it's
certainly it's worth the $8 that's for
dang sure bruh and outside of that Ozark
is those are just the same episode over
and over again I feel like every episode
these people just can't [ __ ] figure it
out and the Sun keeps getting a little
bit older literally the Sun that the the
boy they have is like watching them I
mean he just every episode I feel like
he gets about about two months older
which is pretty fascinating but that's
my thoughts on the louis c.k special
sincerely it's called in and and go
check it out let me know what you think
i think he's probably gonna be the
future where comedians are gonna put
their specials out specifically in a one
locale on their on their own but it was
interesting man I mean it was God there
were some parts what would the best part
is you're like man I do not I don't it's
not that you don't want he'll get into a
topic you're like oh this is something I
shouldn't be laughing about and then
you're like damn I'm [ __ ] really
laughing about this so then you start to
realize that there's this other thing
and there's this other person inside of
you this other different entity than the
facade that we put on sometimes and that
that entity just likes to laugh and then
it's not as judgmental and it just is
taking things for the value of humor
that's in them and in this special
there's a lot of that it's dark though
dog is dark time don't come at me they
do it
if you then that's it if you don't like
it then you don't like it that's fine
nobody else needs to that I don't mean
everybody else don't need to like it
that means you don't like it so gang
[ __ ] alright I think we get through
everything or as much as I can even
remember right now at the moment but
thank you guys for being a part of the
this past weekend support the sponsors
if you can do something if you if you
got the room to do it in your world you
know do it be supportive you know thank
you guys so much for support in the
podcast I'm happy to be able to be here
this weekend to be able to share some
stuff I'm feeling a little bit better
and hope to slowly be feeling even
better I got some blood work done got
that back you know the guy said I had a
couple of things that were way off and
that was interesting man like the like
lysine levels a couple of different
proteins and stuff so it was real
interesting I'm grateful to be able to
got that blood work cuz you don't know
what's in your body what's in your soup
and I'm saying you running around you
don't know if you got vegetables you got
beef
if you freaking if you freaking bull
your bass or if you've been stroganoff
you feel me breath so I hope you're
doing well man I love you and and uh you
know we're pretty lucky we're pretty
lucky aren't we pretty lucky man abhi we
get to be alive this is it you know we
get to just wouldn't even what are we
even doing I don't know but we get to do
it and this is it you know and this is
it we get to see things and experience
and that is life man this is it you know
this is it and we're making it man and
uh thank you guys for being here today
and I'll see you guys next week I'm
trying to get Nick Swardson to do a zoom
episode with me this week so if you guys
will hit him up on IG and send him
messages and tell him to get on board we
could definitely do that
so hit him up you guys be good to
yourselves man and we just keep making
it you know that
his bishop gun on the way out
[Music]
I've seen all men about a hundred days
almost your mama bleep for my restless
so mom and daddy made a dollar I spilled
but well it's gonna kill me and I still
get wet I'm bound let go come on who's
out there you delivering pies bruh you
UPS you post matin bruh I'm makin wrong
[Music]
you're delivering that hit a lemon
meringue do it
bacon good we've got you show up we got
this
[Music]
making it baby by Bishop gun
and most all of my fans step right
through my end
broken on ammo
if this bottle was an hourglass stops
later I'm about an hour past
I shoulda put it now
but how
I feel
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
here alone in my skin but I'm in 40 good
shape for the shave
[Music]
hey girl
fear
God man his name
i hain't seen old men palpable to date
almost your mama pray for my restless
ah man I wish I could do music don't we
all wish we could do music man oh just
being a damn canary just being a canary
of the world
[Music]
you